[Music]  over watches road hog and his hook  ability are getting tweaked again to  make him a little more effective after  his most recent nerf I'm Matt in this  scheme spot news update is hooked on a  feeling the latest PTR exclusive change  in just how row dogs notorious ability  reacts to characters who are only  partially covered by the environment it  makes it easier to catch them with a  hook and on top of that it won't be as  easy for hooked opponents to escape its  pull if they dart behind slim objects  other changes have also been made two  characters Anna in sombra the duration  of Anna's biotic grenade has been  reduced from five seconds 24 while  sombras hack cooldown has dropped from  12 seconds 28 there's currently no date  for when these changes arrive to the  full game but you can try them in the  PTR right now stay up to date on all the  overwatch news and video game stories  out there stay tuned to gamespot